[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick wright first things first co-host
on fox sports one and uh i love the uh
the shirt there you're flying the colors
what's up mahomes
nice yeah i like it courtesy of the db
show which i do have a question yeah
how the hell did you get my home address
hey i don't share that i it just just
shows up i don't know that i want paulie
seton fritzy certainly not you to know
where i live paulie give uh everybody
nick wright's home address so they
should send him some gear it's a
cul-de-sac yeah
uh i actually i got it from uh jenna
wolfe
why well i had heard of the list of
people i don't need to know where i live
what's happening here yeah thank you
appreciate the swag you're welcome and
written note as well which i did like
yeah that was nice uh aesthetically was
that a win last night for the chiefs
uh listen when you're a gritty defensive
minded team like my hometown chiefs
uh
survive in advance stan patrick that's
where the chiefs are so here can i
let me let me paint the picture for you
okay you know the rosiest terms possible
if i were to tell you there was going to
be a team this team the first month of
the season would have a historically bad
defense this team the second month of
the season would forget how to play
offense this team the entirety of the
season would be on pace to set the
all-time turnover record for modern
football and they would have a schedule
that includes four playoff teams from
last year plus the upstart chargers and
i told you the midway point they're a
game out of first in the division
everybody healthy just added melvin
ingram you might say they might be
turning it around you say nick you're
being a little too optimistic
well vegas doesn't agree with you as you
look at the old line for this weekend
aaron rodgers coming to arrowhead by the
way aaron rodgers they played thursday
the chiefs played last night seems a
little unfair goodell but that's not my
business uh the chiefs are favored in
that game so i say all that to say this
with derek henry out with the bengals
losing to the jets with the ravens up
and down the chargers all of a sudden
falling apart aside from buffalo i don't
think there's a team we can say in the
afc is excellent and i still believe
patrick mahomes is great he hasn't
looked like it the last month so we'll
see it was an ugly win they have to go
win two of their next three against the
packers
raiders and cowboys and then we'll see
but i don't think they're dead i think
it'd be silly to write them off
all right you look at this team and
you know i wonder what their identity is
do they know their identity after eight
games
no because and and that i think is being
used against them which the identity has
been we're going to kill you with the
deep shot
and teams are taking that away but they
are but when you take that away what is
available to you is the easy stuff and
they have been correct in betting
the chiefs won't just take it and last
night on that first drive of the game
they took the easy stuff they drove all
the way down the field but then they
can't help themselves it's second down
is that travis kelsey in the backfield
oh my god he's lateraling to my homes
it's a wasted play and then on third
down you get a little unlucky and a ball
goes off a guy's face mask and then
those things start to snowball i just i
couldn't believe it but i was watching
the game last night i'm like just run
the ball i know it's modern football and
you have my homes but if they are giving
you
eight guys dropping into coverage then
just take the eight yard runs you're
gonna get every time and teams are
correctly betting the chiefs won't be
patient enough and up to this point they
haven't been
if they show that patience they'll have
to come out of it and the moment you
come out of it they kill you because the
skill is still there and mahomes is
still i believe the most talented player
in the league he just hasn't played like
the last month
yeah you start to watch and you wonder
can you be a game manager and
last hour i like and i liken mahomes to
steph curry like they've sort of
reinvented
um
you know their positions yeah but if i
said to steph curry hey there's all the
defense on the perimeter you got to now
take the 15-footer or try to get to the
hoop
is he willing to do or trey young if i
said hey
you can't shoot the three you got to go
inside so your mind says well that's not
who i am my identity
and i wonder about that with mahomes if
you say here's your checkdown here's
your seven yards here's nine maybe throw
a home run
maybe we don't have spectacular players
maybe we take a tom brady approach where
we just kind of get it down the field
and that's hard and i would tr i would
change the step analogy a little bit to
not step you take the 15-footer steph
you get to the hoop steph
we're going to post up wiseman and i
promise you it'll work because the guy
on them is six one they're putting all
their length on the perimeter just give
it to him you'll get a layup and i think
at his heart steph would be like
i don't know that doesn't seem like the
way we play and it's just i i there were
derrick gore was the running back last
night and i found myself saying give him
the ball and even to me i'm like what am
i talking about but it was
it if the defense
is giving that to you the chiefs have to
be willing to take it and there is a
level of they're turning the ball over
24 of the time the next highest teams
are 15 to 18 percent and they're the
jets the jags and the dolphins
in a weird way dan that is a little
reassuring because that is going to
regress to the mean like they're not
going to be the highest turnover team in
the league the rest of the year but i
thought it would regress the mean last
night they had two more and gonna had
three
bills the best team in the nfc
right now you got to give them credit
for it they didn't i didn't think they
were very good this weekend i mean it's
3-3 at the half it was a one it was a
hey and i saw josh allen became the
overwhelming mvp favorite after this
weekend and i guess that's a reaction to
brady uh playing poorly derek henry
going down but the bills are the only
team
that you can say are consistent they had
the terrible performance week one other
than that they've been really good and
the titans had a claim but derek henry's
now done
i don't trust the bengals with that lack
of experience as dynamic as they can be
the ravens make no sense to me they are
at times they look like oh my god
they're the best team in football and
then at times they need a 66 yarder to
beat the lions who are the worst team in
football the chargers looked amazing and
now they've looked terrible so that it
you know i th the nfc is very different
the nfc i was we talked to mercedes
lewis today there's the packers are 7-1
they're in a four-way tie atop the nfc
because the cardinals the cowboys and
the rams and then there's the bucks the
afc is not like that this year are the
cowboys really good or do we want them
to be really good
dan i think they're really good
i
here's
i don't trust mike mccarthy at all as
far as you people talk about clock
management i don't know if i trust mike
mccarthy to tell me what time it is much
less clock management but
the the rest of it dan
they they have micah parsons is awesome
he's awesome randy gregory when he's
been on the field in his career has been
really good trayvon diggs to me is the
real deal you have all that talent on
offense and winning a game like they won
last week with the guy who had thrown
three passes in his career i feel like
the cowboys are almost never properly
rated because for so long they were
overrated by i don't know if you know
there's some people on national
television maybe even some of my
colleagues that are you know big big
cowboys fans just talk about them a lot
um and so
i think sometimes they've been overrated
and now i wonder if they're a touch
underrated winning that game against a
tough vikings team with cooper rush
after you fall down seven nothing
immediately is to me is a pretty gritty
impressive win
he's nick wright fox sports uh one uh
first things first uh the first month of
the nba season got a
overwhelming storyline
well the celtics are a mess i mean i
don't know if you played the marcus
smart sound but it's odd to me that mark
is smart's like listen tatum and brown
we're proud of them you're proud of them
are you the father you're 27 years old
jaylen brown's 25. like calm down marcus
smarty's like hey marcus smart's like
listen guys
even though at oklahoma state they
didn't run iso plays for me we need to
let marcus cook that's how we're going
to get going uh that's something you
mentioned the warriors warriors look
pretty damn good without clay now i
think it'd be full foolhardy to assume
when he comes back we're getting the
same clay on the defensive end that we
had years before but they look good and
the lakers are going to be a massive
work in progress all year until they
figure out how they want to play that's
going to take 50 games and then
to me the overwhelming story is
is james harden
a great player
under the new rules i don't know the
answer to that he wasn't a great player
he was a good player before he started
breaking basketball in a really smart
way what made him the scoring champ was
getting aligned 13 times a game and
shooting a dozen threes a game he's had
one excellent game this year he shot 18
free throws every other game he's been
okay and if he's not great the nets are
drawing dead and dan i think katie knows
it do you see katie this weekend threw
the ball under the stands randomly that
was odd the next game he elbows kelly
olynyk gets thrown out that was odd i
think kd's a little frustrated so those
are to me the stories so far
exchange explain the uh the new rule
change and how it's affecting not only
james harden but you know other scores
around the league
well i think it's affecting you the
three guys that should affect the most
are hardened trey and steph steph is
leading the league in scoring trey has
been fine it's affecting a little bit
expected harden a ton what the nba
essentially said is
if there is a foul but it is generated
because the offensive player does what i
call a jabroni move or a non-basketball
move uh you know tries to essentially
trick the ref or trick the defender
we're not going to call it so
what once upon a time the only guy who
really did it was chris paul and chris
paul would do it in the open court he'd
be dribbling super fast there's no guys
behind me just stop god run him over be
a foul it's like oh that's kind of smart
james harden and again i give him credit
for this
figured out oh i can
i can instead of trying to make a basket
i can try to draw a foul so he would do
things to basically just position the
defender's arm between his arms and then
instead of going in a shooting motion he
would just throw his arms in the air and
the nba said we're not having it anymore
and it has really affected him like
drastically affected him and i don't
judge him for that just like i don't
john lynch i don't say well john lynch
isn't a great player because under these
rules he wouldn't have been as effective
hardin harden was great under the rules
he was playing by they just changed the
rules on him
and maybe he could have adjusted but
when you play one way for eight years
like dan i'm sure once upon a time your
game had a lot to do with athleticism
for the last 25 years you've just been
an old man jump shooter it's hard to
adjust right i mean i would assume yeah
you don't play basketball with me even
though i've asked have you
i mean i asked you to go fishing i asked
you to go to a football game i actually
play basketball but i don't have your
home address i send it to the studio
probably gets lost with all your other
merch
i just i i don't know you sounded kind
of desperate and that's why i like i got
nervous with your desperation for
friendship
well dan i don't have many friends i
know i know
i thought you were gonna be one and no
you just used me for these takes uh you
know last year i gave you three months
of content when i said texas barbecue
sucked you haven't had me on since and
uh
how'd that work out for you
i worked out great for you you were like
oh hey boys what's the show
play the nick sound again we're gonna
bring on the grill man
like okay
all right hall of famer did you did you
catch any heat for the uh texas i don't
know man i the
my twitter's just always on fire i just
mute everyone i just i you know my
twitter's a one-way conversation me
giving the takes and receiving none of
it which is why i was so concerned when
a package showed up to my house
but it's all right by the way uh i had
to point out to the rams their their
twitter account when they uh had the
teddy kgb all lost
the rounders clip and i i thought oh i
like that you're all in but somebody
should have told somebody in the rams
office watch the rest of the movie can i
say something real quick about that i
don't know how if we're late just real
quick okay if the rams win the super
bowl it's fine
the rams
everyone's like oh my god the rams look
at how they're running their team anyone
could run their team like that if you me
and seton were in a who can have the
coolest car competition and i took all
the equity out of my house and maxed out
all my credit cards i'd probably win but
i might be screwed long term the rams to
me
they are
you know uh an inventor that knows
they've got the next great thing and
they might but they also might liquidate
everything come up just short and just
be screwed i think it is an incredibly
risky gambit and if you're the broncos
he was going to walk for nothing you got
a second and a third for nine games of
von miller it's a great move for the
broncos maybe the rams win the super
bowl they don't win the super bowl i
think they're in real real rough shape
with the way they're running that team
let's have nick back soon guys what do
you think
yeah
sure what well sure that wasn't
let me try this again dropped an f-bomb
i know sure let me let me try it again
let's have nick on again guys all right
how about tomorrow yeah two segments
maybe next hour
yeah next hour yeah i'm not available
i'm going i'm going fishing with my
green bird
you're you're going you're looking for
friends
looking for friends uh i'm gonna be on
the corner of 125th and linux in harlem
america if you want to just
talk sports see you guys there thank you
bud good to have you on again nick thank
you you too that's uh a guy a really
desperate guy looking for friendship a
little thirsty yeah he is yes that would
be thirsty